stunning news out of Washington
President Trump revokes the security
clearance of former CIA director John
Brennan press secretary Sarah
Sanders reading a statement from the
president explaining why any benefits
that senior officials might glean from
consultations with mr. Brennan are now
outweighed by the risks posed by his
erratic conduct and behavior mr.
Brennan's line and recent conduct
characterized by increasingly frenzied
commentary is wholly inconsistent with
access to the nation's most closely held
secrets and facilities the very aim of
our adversaries which is to sow division
and chaos Brennan the now MSNBC
contributor is a constant critic of
President Trump here he is just last
night I think Donald Trump has badly
sullied the reputation of the office of
the presidency with his invective with
his constant disregard I think for human
decency as well as his befriended of
water crack leaders around the world and
his continued pursuit of relationships
to benefit himself as opposed to country
I do think that America's standing in
the world has also been tarnished but I
think even more fundamentally what he is
doing here in the United States is very
polarizing and he is I think the most
divisive president we've ever had in the
Oval Office
fresh reaction from John Brennan on
Twitter quote this action is part of a
broader effort by mr. Trump to suppress
freedom of speech and punish critics it
should gravely worry all Americans
including intelligence professionals
about the cost of speaking out my
principles are worth far more than
clearances I will not relent the White
House is also now reviewing security
clearances of top former intelligence
officials and FBI employees including
James Comey Andrew McCabe Susan Rice
Peter struck and James clapper all right
judge anine oh I know you've been
following first this is Brendan
situation very closely they say these
people retain their clearances to
consult with their successors I don't
think he's doing
a consultation now and just as a
professional courtesy do you believe he
has forfeited his professional courtesy
by the frenzied rhetoric that he's been
exhibiting on cable TV and on Twitter
well he certainly has been engaging in a
lot of frenzied behavior and criticism
but here's the bottom line you're not
entitled to a security clearance you
don't have a right to have it the
president it has the arbitrary right to
take it away how many people do we know
whether or not they have it or don't
have it
when does it sunset and here's the guy
who's lied to Congress a million times
that's an exaggeration you know he he
denied the CIA that he was running
improperly access computer files of the
Senate it's all in my book which we'll
talk about later but he use it but
here's the thing look the guy is he is
this truth to power nonsense that you
need to be able to have this it's really
for an institutional reference nobody in
Pompeo ain't calling this guy right so
why does he need it and you know I have
no problem with it they're not tied to
it all right so one judge Jeanine
brought up one of the issues at stake
for the fact that he lied about spying
on Senate staffers he also lied to
Congress when he says oh we don't listen
to Americans phone calls in bulk and he
also lied about the use of the dossier
said it wasn't really considered in the
intelligence assessment which it was so
three things there alone the guy
preferring false information to Congress
and to the American people he doesn't
have a great track record when it comes
to honesty I think he has a great track
record and I think he's a patriot I tell
you I'm to me I don't understand why
Michael Flynn's not on that list you
have any idea why Mike wins not know I
think we know on any Republican not on
the list what you think of is on the
list is he's still a Republican so if
that's not it necessary this again you
know he puts comb he puts McCabe they
don't even have clearance OD but he puts
them on the list because it essentially
and you hear this now from the Democrats
he's created an enemies list so he
attacks the
presses the anenome of the American
people he attacks his critics he makes
people who work for him signed
non-disclosure agreements hosts
transparency huh and then of course he's
trying to now politicize intelligence
gathering he does not consult with Jim
clapper his own Director of National
Intelligence about this move so to me
this is like so sad and so authoritarian
and yet I've suppose all these
supporters will guess they are a big
deal I think you meant Coates Dena is
this is just rare I mean has this ever
happened before I think it's I think
it's not an exaggeration to say it's
unprecedented but as the judge says the
President does have the right to make
this decision but I look at as this way
why today well solve a problem like
Omarosa by having something to lead with
today this document is actually dated
July 26 they didn't change that today
when they released it so they've been
holding on to it maybe because of
Brennan's comments last night on MSNBC
they decided that was just the last
straw and they decided to move forward
but it did provide the White House a way
to pivot to the story that they want to
talk about of the day and that is this
issue it's very clever the use of the
word erratic because it's not just a
word that they pick out a thin air
erratic is one of the words that you're
asked about when you are going through a
clearance or when you're your friends
and colleagues or your former work
associates they'll be asked
did you ever see Jesse exhibit erratic
behavior because that would be a tell
that there might be something wrong with
them and they would not be able to deal
with that I do think it looks a little
bit like political retaliation but the
president has the ability to do it so if
he wants to do it fine I just don't
think it actually does anything beyond
this new cycle because John Brennan's
not gonna stop talking he's not even
using his security clearance anyway all
right Greg welcome back thanks for
having me back Jesse your hair is as big
as ever
you've you've been missed on your book
tour what do you think about this latest
clearance revoking well I think when
when people say this is unprecedented
that doesn't matter anymore because
everything since 2016 is unprecedented
and so we also when you have complaints
about behavior emotional behavior
brennan's kritis
of Trump or also pointless because we've
been through that he's still one you can
still think he's a jerk he still beat
the pants off you so get over it so
there are two big reasons here Brennan
is just another person who was broken by
2016
he's like the reverse version of the
movie big instead of a child becoming a
man he is transformed from a man to a
petulant child by some supernatural
surreal event that which was the 2016
election this has happened to a lot of
people
he's fallen and he can't get off I think
this is trumped arrangements Aleut lee
and also i the second reason is and why
his opinion means nothing to me
is back in the 80s at the height of the
Cold War thank you Brennan voted for a
communist in the freest country we have
ever seen he has no standing to be
critical about any Russian any Russian
meddling or any kind of Russian policy
because he didn't just collude he
cheerlead he Cheerilee at a time when we
really needed people there to fight it
to be an anti-communist so the fact that
he got this far is astounding I look
forward to his books I know there will
be one and the other thing about this
yeah I understand the idea of pivoting
but in in Trump world news is bocce ball
so the ball comes the ball will be al
Moroso and the next fall will be Brennan
but the fact is you can't tell the
difference between that being pivoting
or just being another day because every
day I also think it's quite strategic
yeah I think they would do it every day
I think they do this every day like you
wake up every day thinking you want to
be proactive and ya end up having to
react to things Brennan last night in
the clip that we saw here he's reacting
to Trump calling Omarosa a dog and then
so what Brennan says is that he's failed
to live up the president has failed to
live up to minimum standards of decency
it's disheartening and dangerous for a
president to behave in that way for our
nation how dangerous though how
dangerous how ugly how disheartening but
you know what the problem is one the
problem is that you've got Brennan and
clapper the people who lied to Congress
who anyone else you know would be in
jail right now but these are the guys
who are monetizing and politicizing
these are the guys who were actually
going on television and if you don't
think that security clearance adds to
their ability to be lobbyists and
consultants and advisers it's huge
they're monetizing it but Michael Flynn
is not the guy he's hiding somewhere
rapid I think it's monetizing to say
that he was the CIA director he was how
did he get on MSNBC got on CNN because
he lied and said he never leaked
anything then we find out he leaks
something to CNN and then he's out
getting a check from 4 million people
judge who have security clearance in the
country I think it's a million plus who
had top secret clearance million three
right so these guys aren't monetizing
these are what we need to build a wall
around the people with clearances he's
leveraging his clearance order to gain
credibility when he goes on television
makes these really outrageous statements
some of these statements he says the
President of the United States is a
danger to national security he suggested
Trump met one-on-one with Vladimir Putin
because he was hiding something from his
own security team he says the president
has no credibility and he says he he is
a Ponzi scheme artist comparing him to
Bernie Madoff and he said this is all
gonna catch up with him kind of making
these veiled threats like oh you're a
security clearance
right so it's like it doesn't
necessarily matter he's now that he has
the reputation he has now that he's down
he's done he will always be able to be
on television he'll always be able to
write books that like that is not this
doesn't change that for him but I do
think it is professionally embarrassing
it is you know what most Americans agree
with what you said Brennan believes
which is the Trump is lying about his
relations with Russia and the Trump's
not yeah that's what surveys show that
the Americans are not the least bit
interested in the Russians and yet
people have to be very skeptical of
somebody this emotional Brennan is
emotional wreck right now you can't
there's something going on in his head
you know that's not right he's erratic
he's a rat